the heart of this book of course is the
love affair between yourself and
Harrison
now given that it did happen 40 years
ago I was just remembered but there were
I suppose there's what one does that but
also that it has caused a sensation you
would think the people gotta go Oh two
young actors yeah of course they didn't
why they had an affair but this is cause
ructions it four hundred thousand news
services picked it up Wow I own every
team a little embarrassing for me but
here's the thing I do find this
extraordinary so 40 years ago you have
this affair over the months of the the
movie and you say you literally never
spoke about it again I think what I'm
seeing you guys oh my
more on the know everything I became
friends with his second wife then and so
we saw each other a lot and no I can
literally remember three times that we I
of course made some oblique reference to
it and he went on but of course
everything is now he's gonna have to
talk about it for the rest of his life
that's what you I never thought of that
and leave it to branch and now and now I
feel more guilty because just a quote on
the front
isabell get a good read
[Music]
you
[Music]